so many children in the theater Rio is
the new animated tale and it's by the
director of the three Ice Age movies and
one thing I really want to say is that
this film actually starts with a short
film it's a scratch short film it's the
you know the scroll from Ice Age it was
great I loved it Rio's about a bird
named Blu voiced by Jesse Eisenberg from
the social network and he can't fly
he's been domesticated for a very young
age has learned that he's a very rare
species of bird in fact he's the last
male of his kind and the only other
remaining bird of that species is a
female so scientists want them to mate
so that they can continue their species
on so they think I'm down to Brazil so
he can get it on and and so events
happen he gets lost and he's now lost in
Brazil and he has to figure out how to
get back to his owner who he very much
loves he meets the girl that he's
supposed to mate with which is kind of
funny for a g-rated movie and so it's
like a fun little coming-of-age tale of
this bird learning about things and you
know he can't fly so that's really hard
for him and he kind of likes this girl
and he meets a lot of interesting people
along the way Rio was a fun movie it's
it's definitely good for kids but it has
fun things for adults too it's not just
strictly for kids like Mars Needs Moms
was oh my word
this movies a lot more fun and it has
really nice visuals really crisp visuals
and the 3d is good I will stress though
if you're an older teen or an adult who
wants to see this film I I might suggest
you seeing it more later in the day like
at 9 or 10 o'clock because if there's a
lot of children in your theater and the
earlier part of the day they can get
really annoying
I saw a screening of this and it was
packed and there were just so many
children and just talk talk talk talk
talk and after a while it was okay I
mean
but it was just be careful with that
voice acting is very good for all the
people who do their roles I really
enjoyed it usually I'm not a big fan of
when they have singing and I'm in movies
where they just break out in a song over
something I actually might in this movie
it wasn't overused and the songs were
fun and I was going like this a few
times it was good I mean there was a lot
of Spanish influence to the music you
know I mean that took place in Brazil
and everything and there's a lot of
humor in it and a lot of heart I mean
this is no Rango this note or Story 3
but it is a fun children's film and it
has good animation so I would suggest
seeing Rio soon as the bird talked I was
like that's Mark Zuckerberg from the
Facebook Murphy yeah Jesse Eisenberg did
a really nice job and Anne Hathaway
played Jule the love interest bird I
just found it really funny how like the
first 20 minutes were all about the bird
trying to find the woman so they can
mate and like all these children are
just like the whole first part of the
movie is like are they gonna mate it's
like it's kind of weird I guess after
Rango and all the scary parts and all
the killing and everything in that movie
than this movie now we have mating birds
I mean like they're getting up there
with the kids movies these days but Rio
is a fun movie your kids will probably
enjoy it and you probably won't mind
watching it either
I'll give it three out of four stars I
really wish they'd stop at the 3d but it
wasn't that bad in this film I just it's
just a distraction you know I just I
want to go back to old days
2d
you